where's the line between moral depravity
and demonic possession cbs's
Supernatural crime drama evil suggests
the line might not be so obvious not
until it's too late the show follows a
secular forensic psychologist played by
Katya herbers a mystical Catholic priest
in training played by Mike Coulter and a
died in the wolf skeptic played by ASF
Mani as they try to get to the bottom of
crimes of great evil the series
premiered in September 2019 to strong
ratings and the first season was added
to Netflix this October new viewers have
been using the streaming service to get
a acquainted with Evil's mix of
satisfying police procedural and genuine
scares propelling the show onto
Netflix's top 10 list exactly what about
evil has been capturing audien's
attention here are a few things you
should know about the terrifying crime
drama that is currently taking over
Netflix okay all right I will make the
sacrifice and watch the whole thing well
this is no time for bravery I'm going to
let you unal drct Kristen Bard finds
herself out of a job after working on
the case of a killer who claims he
committed his crimes while under the
influence of demonic possession she
getss the opportunity to continue her
profile of the killer thanks to David
aosta a trainee priest who investigates
cases of possession from a religious
perspective and a skeptical but loyal
contractor Ben Shakir although the two
begin to work together they come at each
case from two distinct viewpoints Dr
brushard defaults to Scientific
explanations while aosta leaves the door
open for the possibility of the
supernatural M Bard please take this for
your own
protection trust me you may need
it the character Conflict at the center
of evil mirrors the dynamic between the
show's creators Michelle and Robert King
of The Good Wife and the good fight Fame
as Michelle King explained to the rap
Robert's more religious so he typically
goes toward a Divine explanation I'm
more secular so I tend to think things
are the result of psychology or science
this real life dichotomy between the
husband and wife Duo fuels the ethos of
evil but deciding what's real and what's
imaginary is far from the point to the
show in fact the cre creators in the
series are more interested in exploring
the gray area between the two ideas as
Robert King told the rap if you're of
the scientific or empirical Bend you
have to acknowledge that there are
psychopaths in the world you don't have
to believe in demons to believe that
there are lone gunmen who influence each
other to kill if you are of the
spiritual band you might say okay
there's an element where these human
beings cross over into demonic Behavior
so what is the difference it shouldn't
come as too much of a surprise that evil
has been a hit with Netflix viewers as
it was a critical success when it
premiered the show effectively chilling
scares and strong chemistry between its
leads were noted by many and it even
garnered favorable comparisons to the X
Files in our investigations you may not
always agree with me but at least you
respect the journey the first season's
enviable 91% score on Rotten Tomatoes
would be a feat in and of itself but the
series also appeared on several critics
lists of the best TV shows of 2019 TV
lines Rebecca yucci included evil on her
list of the 10 best drama series of 2019
and wrote the cases of the week are are
Flatout scary in a way broadcast network
Supernatural dramas usually are not PE
Sur prizewinning TV critic Emily nus
bomb of the New Yorker agreed with Yan
uchi's assessment about the show scares
in her own best of Roundup writing it
clicks owing to the chemistry of The
Ensemble Katya Herber Mike Coulter an as
of Moni and its willingness to be legit
scary at NPR David bian culi added the
series to his top 10 series of 2019 list
and said this series proves commercial
broadcast network still could produce
and present a smart entertaining TV
drama series if it hired the right
people and left them alone you don't
care that I don't
believe I do
not with all that critical heat behind
it it seems inevitable that we'll be
seeing evil season 2 sometime soon right
based on the good ratings critical
praise and success on Netflix CBS itself
would have to be facing a case of
demonic possession to not renew evil for
a second season and sure enough the show
officially got picked up less than a
month after it began airing however even
even though we're well into the
beginning of the Fall TV season there's
still no sign of season 2 evil is facing
delays thanks to the ongoing disruptions
to the TV and film industry however
there is some good news on the horizon
for the show's second season back in
August 2020 series co-lead ASF mby gave
an interview with inverse during which
he was asked about the status of evil
season 2 he answered there are a lot of
conversations between the networks
unions and New York State about safety
from what I've heard we'll start in the
next few months I hope sooner than later
then in September 2020 deadline
entertainment reporter Nelly Andria
reported that while evil still hadn't
been greenlit to start filming it was on
the preus of getting the go-ahead if the
show does indeed begin filming in the
fall of 2020 that would likely mean
we'll see season 2 premiere on CBS
sometime in the winter of 2020 or the
beginning of 2021 that gives you plenty
of time to join the possessed masses and
catch up on evil season 1 on Netflix
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more Looper videos about
your favorite movies and TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the Bell so you don't
miss a single
[Music]
one